[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
so marius
at last i find you
tyrio
yes
they're always watching i've been
searching for you for a long time malius
i was rather beginning to think you
didn't want to be found
oh forgive me tyrion please
it
it wasn't my fault
not your fault tell me malice how was it
not your fault
the wanderer
yes
it was
was the wanderer
my days in the rogue citadel seemed so
long ago
i sought refuge
from my memories in the company of other
outcasts
high in the mountains past the eastern
gate
[Music]
oh i fought sleep
for days at a time
for when i dreamt
the memories
would
return memories of the monastery
and the evil
which it claimed
three memories
i couldn't tell the difference anymore
and the evil from my dreams
followed me at my heels
how had he found me here
look at this broken shell of a man
barely able to carry the weight of his
own spawn
be the burning terror
which drove me to hide here
he seemed
to have demons of his own
he struggled to contain
was losing
[Music]
as i watched
i became convinced
that i was truly mad
the terror
the destruction leader the evil i
witnessed
how else could i explain them
were these the demons from my dream
were they born
within the wonder
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
why did i follow him
i don't know
why do things happen as they do in
dreams
all i know is that when he beckoned
i had to follow him
but from that moment
we traveled together east
always
into the east
[Music]
we traveled east
over the mountains and into the vast
deserts of broken lands
[Music]
as the days passed my companion told me
of himself
that he had once been a great warrior
and that a dark and sacred burden
now
weighed heavily on him
we traveled for an eternity across that
aran wasteland how long
i couldn't say
and always
a dark cloud seemed to follow us
just over the horizon
finally the journey ended we climbed the
last bridge
there below us lay
our destination
the shining jewel
blue
lane
with a great sea beyond
we made camp that last night
perhaps it was the warm desert wind or
the sound of the ocean but for the first
time in many weeks
i slept however
the dreams returned but these were
clearly not my own i beheld the vision
of a great man the mage tell russia you
were there too material i remember
seeing you in my dream
his brethren had cornered a great demon
a veil of the lord of destruction who
had been set loose upon the world
and they attempted to imprison the demon
within a sacred stone
yet whether attempts failed
tarasha selflessly volunteered to
contain the demon within himself
completing the prison
he instructed his brethren to find him
within a tomb
buried under the sand and there to
wrestle with the demon for all eternity
now you know what i seek marius
this is my brother
sleep now
we set out with the dawn
the next morning we walked over the hill
toward
luke colleen
i had no idea then
of the horrors that were in store for me
there
you